it's Halloween none of them are even
dressed up not one costume what's
happened what's how you do a miracle I
don't know I'm not where I mean I'm just
sort of like a substitute teacher but
well no I you know it's me I don't even
have a costume this year yeah here's my
plan I'm going to take off my makeup and
go out as the human circulatory system
[Applause]
you know that sounds like a joke it
almost isn't a joke and excuse me all
the time no makeup on it's just veins
veins veins and freckles yeah every now
and then yeah he's like looks like a
small tumor right there get that checked
out my son really wants to scare people
this Halloween so he's going as Trump's
second term
he gets candy and people moved to New
Zealand you know this is a we should
want to talk about tonight every
Halloween we hear a story about kids
receiving candy that's been tampered
with I mean I've been hearing about that
so yeah I was a caterer ever apps yeah
forever when I was a kid don't say oh
you can't look out make sure you leave
you know which house you're going to all
that kind of stuff and really it becomes
every parent's nightmare well ladies and
gentlemen luckily there's a new
organization that can help hi I'm Matt
Johnson the CEO of CBI
every October hundreds of millions of
children literally take candy from
strangers and put it directly into their
mouths are you kidding me think of the
things that demented mind could stick
into a candy bar razors needles
landmines polio arrowheads even oatmeal
with CBI you'll have 24/7 access to a
trained investigator me who will check
every piece of candy so this doesn't
happen to your child all right don't
worry mom I got this there's fun
let's go
the location is secure happy Halloween
thank you I need to use your bathroom
CBI
let me us eat it for you
during the Lord's work and you think
about it